[Applause]
thank you
hi okay your outfit is so amazing by the
way okay
you are a human bouquet yes you really
have written something that is raw
vulnerable real confident poetic and I
just absolutely love the way that you
write
um so you put out this tweet and it was
about you know you had just done
Hustlers with Serene this is literally
like one of my oldest and dearest
friends so
um you know you do her film Hustlers
your career trajectory is skyrocketing
you throw out some tweets and you're
you're on a show and one of the things
that a lot of people don't understand is
there's a reason people are scared to
get on a television show is because they
have you under contract for almost
literally what canir a decade and you
chose to speak out about that and talk
about the re realities of what that is
and there was aftermath about that how
dare you how what wait you we don't talk
about these things yeah I mean I didn't
I don't think I chose to do it I think I
was a little bit impulsive and Reckless
um because I did have big feelings
because I had suppressed a lot of abuse
I'd suffered over the years on that show
in an attempt to sort of preserve its
reputation because it was such a like
shining Beacon of representation for
Asian Americans yep and for me to talk
about the sexual harassment that I
suffered the first two years at the
hands of a producer who had done so much
great work for the Asian American
Community it was such a conflict in my
heart because it's like on the other
hand he does all this great work for the
Asian American Community but he's also
like sexually harassing me and saying
inappropriate things and controlling me
but saying it's really he's protecting
me is what he was saying and I was so
new to the industry I had just like quit
waitressing a few months prior to fresh
off the boat and I was scared of being
fired I kind of reached a boiling point
and I behaved out of character but when
this happened it felt like my whole
Community turned against me like the
Asian American community and really
wanted to shave me so much to the point
where one of my former Asian colleagues
an actress
dm'd me and told me that I was a
disgrace and a blight on the community
and that essentially she said that it
would be better if I just didn't exist
and I yeah I ended up almost killing my
myself and I ended up in the psychiatric
ER of um of the hospital because my
friend found me and you know took me
and it really made me like I thought
that I could handle it but it really
made me reevaluate everything I had been
holding back for all those years in
service of helping the Asian American
community and it made me realize
actually I think the Asian American
Community needs to own up to its history
of sexism misogyny and patriarchal
values because we don't talk about that
because all we're talking about is
positive representation which is an
illusion nobody is all positive we need
whole human representation thank you
you know
I love your boldness I love your bravery
and I do believe that it will go out
there and matriculate to other people
finding their courage figuring out ways
in which to put them that are cathartic
healthy channels
um you know you talk about your
relationship with your sister why are
sisters and that relationship so complex
that's actually my favorite chapter it
is yeah I mean it's so special because I
don't think we often see the complexity
of it we either see it as catfight or
like oh we love each other and it's
there are so many colors in between and
it continues to evolve it's not like a
static relationship I talk about how we
were really close when we were kids and
then when I went to middle school it
kind of fractured because she started
having her own friends and I was scared
that she didn't like me or need me
anymore so I acted like I didn't need
her
and our relationship became kind of
fractured and then when I brought this
essay back to her to be like hey I wrote
this is it okay if I publish it
she wrote me back and she said I think
the one thing you're missing is that I
was your follower and that I missed you
too and that broke my heart because all
those years ago I thought she didn't
need me anymore and that's what hurt me
and she said I missed you too and now
we're even closer she's about to have a
kid of her own no it's like it keeps
evolving and growing you know so funny
whenever anyone asks me about my two
daughters like do they get along I'm
like there is no simple answer yes
sometimes yes and sometimes not and
it'll continue to evolve but they'll
always be sisters always what and that's
what it is you know there's sort of an
old-fashioned nature to television of
the 60s and 70s where we got to sit down
and kind of have these interesting
conversations and so I wanted to hearken
back to that time and we built the set
and this is the very first segment we're
doing on it wow
thank you thank you
for kicking off this room in a way that
I could have only ever wished to have
these kinds of conversations because I
like to be silly I like to be funny I'm
like a complete saber I I love crying I
already cried once during the interview
and I love that you're a sober I am too
let's make something cool exactly and
what do you do when I sob I eat I like I
like to eat my feelings I like to I like
comfort food I like something similar to
eating
um it's another sensory thing which is
you know aromatherapy certain scents
just calm you down like walking back
memories like a freshly baked cinnamon
roll which I used to make at the bakery
it's like it's the most amazing smell
you can't be unhappy when you smell a
freshly baked cinnamon roll you make
cinnamon rolls yes
will you teach me how to make your
cinnamon rolls I would love to teach you
seriously yes
[Music]
foreign